Yeah,
well a few tyrannized people badly
enough,
they'll actually hurt themselves to hurt
you so you know,
they're willing to take a willing to
take a hit to reclaim justice,
let's say.
So yeah,
that's really worth knowing.
And so one of the things that John
Piaget pointed out and because he was,
he's a very interesting psychologist and
he's never taught properly because you
know,
most of these great thinkers were very
strange people and the strangeness Gets
Edited Out of their stories and it's
really too bad because they're way more
interesting when you know how strange
they were and so piaget was obsessed
with the disjunction between religion
and science and his goal as a thinker
was to reconcile the two.
And so to some degree he was looking for
a biological basis of morality.
That might be one way of thinking about
it or at least to reconcile the idea of
a biological substrate with an emergent
morality.
And one of the things he said is,
okay,
imagine two systems.
All right,
so both systems are moving towards a
goal,
any old arbitrary goal and in one system
the the people within it are acting
under compulsion and in the other system
that people within it are acting
voluntarily said the people who are
acting voluntarily will defeat the
people acting under compulsion because
in order to use compulsion,
you have to spend a fair bit of time and
energy on force and so it makes you
inefficient.
Whereas if everybody is together on the
project,
then they'll.
You don't have to spend any time on
compulsion because people are compelling
themselves and so that's what he called
an equilibrium state.
So in equilibrium state was,
well,
we sit down and we have a negotiation.
That's a real negotiation.
So it,
it has to be honest and we say,
okay,
well what the hell are we doing?
And everyone hash that out and we decide
what we're doing and then we decide how
that would be good for all of us,
but each of us singularly as well.
So if you've got your family put
together property,
then the whole family moves together,
but everybody inside moves ahead as
well,
and so then everybody's pushing in the
same,
you know,
you know how it is in a negotiation.
You actually want your interests to
align with the interests of the other
person because then you don't have to
worry about the integrity of the deal.
It's like everybody has reasons to keep
it,
to keep it thriving,
and the idea that capitalism in somehow
is somehow is predicated on the tyranny
of the people at the,
at the pinnacle that happens when it
gets corrupt,
but it doesn't happen at all when it's
working properly because deals that
aren't based on mutual self interest and
group interests simultaneously have to
be enforced usually with lawyers and
then you're done,
right?
You're done.
At that point.